I think one hero i would mention is
Galileo and the reason for that and the
reason I think least to my mind he's the
greatest scientist is the way we do
science now is to actually have ideas
that we can test with experiments and
it's this it's called the scientific
method so critical to making science
more than philosophy and anything in
earlier civilizations the Greeks the
Romans the greatest minds of
philosophers they just sort of intuited
thanks you know here's the way things
must be and of course that's a recipe
for making a lot of mistakes and for
having a false impression of the world
and we go away oh did was to say okay I
have an idea but I think the way to go
is to do experiments and to test the
ideas and that I think is is the bedrock
upon which modern science is built also
I mean he took a lot of heat for what he
did in his lifetime from the Catholic
Church and and he was operating under a
pretty extreme circumstances and given
those circumstances I think he performed
pretty darn well